[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the Potter
family specifically in the context of
their wealth the Potter surname holds
great significance in The Wizarding
World thanks to one particular member of
the family Harry Potter known as The Boy
Who Lived Harry's extraordinary Journey
serves as an inspiring story to those in
the Wizarding World and has captivated
millions of readers and movie goers
worldwide however the history of the
Potter family extends far beyond Harry's
remarkable life from their ancestral
roots to the trials and triumphs faced
by previous generations the tale of the
Potters unveils a captivating Narrative
of Honor sacrifice and resilience today
we'll be taking a journey back through
time and exploring the rich and
intriguing history of the Potter family
who were Harry's grandparents great
grandparents great great grandparents
and how did the boy who lived come to
inherit such a large sum of gold
gallions in the first book Let's dive in
Origins the Potter family boasts an
ancient magical lineage that stretches
back through generations with many
Potters leaving behind their own unique
stamp on the Wizarding
World however it wasn't until more
recent years that the family name was
truly catapulted to stardom the Potter
family is a very old one but it was
never until the birth of Harry James
Potter at the very Forefront of Whiting
history contenting itself with a solid
and comfortable existence in the
backwaters poter is a not uncommon
muggle surname and the family did not
make the so-called sacred 28 for this
reason the anonymous compiler of that
supposedly definitive list of pure
Bloods suspected that they had sprung
from what he considered to be tainted
blood for Generations The Potters were
known as a pure blood family with a
strong Association to Gryffindor House
at Hogwarts however given the
commonality of Potter as a muggle
surname as well as their commitment to
equality and rejection of blood Purity
they were subsequently excluded from the
sacred 28 a list of the most prestigious
and seemingly pure Widing families and
the Potters didn't just exist in Britain
there was also a whole other branch of
the family that had established
themselves in the United States likely
sometime around the late
1600s Abraham Potter was one of these
American family members and he also just
so happened to be among the original 12
auras trained and appointed by the first
ever president of the magical Congress
of United States of America Josiah
Jackson in this sense The Potters
cemented their place in America even
sooner than they did in Britain
apparently descendants of Abraham have
received consider able respect in
America ever since however this American
side of the family didn't come from
nowhere nor did the British side they
had to start somewhere and that
somewhere was with the founding
patriarch of The Wizarding Potter family
lynfred of Sting com emphasis is placed
on the word Wizarding here because in
muggle World Potter is a very well
established occupational surname
stemming from those who created Pottery
The Wizarding family of Potters descends
from the 12th century wizard lynfred of
stinchcomb a locally well-beloved and
eccentric man whose nickname the
potterer became corrupted in time to
Potter lindred was a vague and
absent-minded fellow whose muggle
neighbors often called upon his
medicinal Services none of them realized
that lyf's wonderful cures for pox and
egg were magical they all thought him a
harmless and lovable old chap pottering
about in his garden with all his funny
plants his reputation as a well-meaning
eccentric served ly well for behind
closed doors he was able to continue the
series of experiments that laid the
foundation of the Potter family's
Fortune undoubtedly lfred was quite an
accomplished man and he is fairly
credited as the Potter family's
patriarch but interestingly if you dig
back far enough there are actually some
other influential figures we can point
to when digging deep within their
history the rise of ignotus pil deep
within the Potter family's history lies
the story of ignotus Peril a pivotal
figure whose Legacy has reverberated
through the
generations ignotus and his involvement
in the legend of death the Hallows has
helped further shape the Potter family's
identity and left an enduring imprint on
their lineage while not technically a
Potter himself ignotus was the
grandfather of Ian perril who married
hardwin Potter some of drum roll pleas
lynfred of stenc com lyford's eldest son
hardwin married a beautiful young Witch
by the name of Ian pevl who came from
the village of godric's hollow she was
the granddaughter of ignotus pevl in the
absence of male a she the eldest of her
generation had inherited her
grandfather's invisibility cloak it was
Ian explained to hardwin a tradition in
her family that the possession of this
cloak remained a secret and her new
husband respected her wishes from this
time on the cloak was handed down to the
eldest in each new generation ignotus
pil was one of the three brothers who
possessed the Deathly Hallows powerful
magical artifacts that are said to Grant
extraordinary abilities to their
wielders among the Three Brothers
ignotus was the one who possessed the
invisibility cloak which has since been
passed down through the generations of
the Potter family in the tale of the
Deathly Hallows Three Brothers encounter
death himself and have subsequently
granted three miraculous objects as a
reward for their cunning and skill these
objects included the El the W the
resurrection Stone and the invisibility
cloak and ever since ignotus first
passed down the wondrous cloak it has
solidified the link between the Potter
family and this extraordinary artifact
after all it was ignotus his son that
gave it to irand starting the tradition
ever since then the cloak has become a
symbol of protection secrecy and the
family's commitment to fighting against
dark Forces and over the years each
generation of Potters has treasured this
cloak utilizing its powers for various
purposes including evading danger and
ultimately contributing to their legacy
of heroism notable potters and wealth
because ignotus was not technically a
Potter lynfred is still technically the
earliest Potter known but lynfred was
known for more than just being the
founding patriarch of the Potter family
he was also known for being the one to
get the ball rolling with regards to the
family's generational wealth remember
Harry's trip to Vault 68 7 in the
philosopher stone well we can thank
lynfred at least partially for that
historians credit lynfred as the
originator of a number of remedies that
evolved into potions still used to this
day including skro and pep potion his
sales of such cures to fellow witches
and wizards enabled him to leave a
significant pile of gold to each of his
seven children upon his death but
lynfred wasn't the only one in the
family to become successful he just
kicked things off The Potters continued
to marry their neighbors occasionally
Muggles and to live in the west of
England for several Generations each one
adding to the family coffers by their
hard work and it must be said by the
quiet brand of Ingenuity that had
characterized their forebear lfred
occasionally a Potter made it all the
way to London and a member of the family
has twice sat on the wizen gamut Rolston
Potter who was a member from 1612 to
1652 and who was a great supporter of
the statute of secrecy and as opposed to
declaring war on the Muggles as more
militant members wish to do and Henry
Potter Harry to his Intimates and while
many of The Potters were able to achieve
success in their respective careers
slowly growing the family fortune it
wasn't until a certain femont Potter
came about that fuel really started to
get added to the fire femont was the son
of Henry and father to you guessed it
James Potter this means that femont was
Harry's grandfather Henry's son was
called fle Potter the font was so called
because it was the dying wish of Henry's
mother that he perpetuate her maiden
name which would Otherwise Die out he
bore the burden remarkably well indeed
he always attributed his dexterity
dueling to the number of times he had to
fight people at Hogwarts after they had
made fun of his name femont may have
never met Harry but he did live long
enough to make and leave him enough gold
for a lifetime you see femont was able
to take the family fortune and quadruple
it by creating the family's most famous
potion to date sik ezy's hair potion the
potion was a hair potion and scalp
treatment marketed with the following
slogan two drops tame even the most
bothersome Barnet it was essentially
used for taming unruly hair sleekly and
fashionably styling it he sold the
company at a vast profit when he retired
but no amount of riches could compensate
him or his wife emia for their
childlessness they had quite given up
hope of a son or daughter when to their
shock and surprise euphemia found that
she was pregnant and their beloved boy
James was born in short the immense
wealth of The Potters can be attributed
to centuries of sales from multiple
successful and extremely prevalent
potions given the long-standing
generational wealth of The Potters it's
certainly not surprising that Harry was
left with an absolute boatload of cash
interwoven families as should be
expected with pure blood visiting
families the Potter family has intricate
ties to several other families in the
The Wizarding World and it all goes back
to the Perle family just like the Potter
family is tied to ignotus it should come
as no surprise that other wisting
families have ties to his brothers
Antioch and Cadmus in fact Cadmus pevl
the brother who chose the resurrection
stone is an ancestor of none other than
Lord Voldemort AKA Tom Riddle this
relation is through the house of gour
and if we take an even closer look at
the family trees of popular Whiting pure
blood families like the black Smo long
bottoms and Weasley you shouldn't be too
surprised to see a Potter or two despite
this fact however The Potters were never
granted a spot on the sacred 28 a
directory of all pure blood Whiting
families while The Potters were indeed
recognized as a pure blood witing family
at the time of the questionable List
publication they certainly aren't now it
turns out they were excluded due to
suspicions from the list compiler and it
was all due to the Potter's connection
to the Muggle world because Potter was
also a common muggle surname the
compiler deduced that the Wizarding
Potters simply couldn't be pure Bloods
he felt as though The Potters must have
sprung from what he considered to be
tainted blood their American branch is
also connected to several families in
the wisting world Legacy the Potter
family is a rich and storied Legacy that
has impacted the wisting world in
numerous ways from ignotus perl's
possession of the invisibility cloak
into font Potter's f anthropic Endeavors
the family is carved out a place in
history as skilled Wizards Innovative
inventors and compassionate
philanthropists at the heart of their
story lies the Journey of Harry Potter
the most renowned member of the family
and a symbol of Hope love and
perseverance the Potter family's Legacy
has extended beyond their individual
achievements and has become a symbol of
resilience determination and the power
of love their unwavering commitment to
using their abilities for the betterment
of society and their acceptance of those
from all walks of life have made them
pioneers of social change in The
Wizarding World this is a family that
has left a truly remarkable Legacy one
that will continue to resonate with us
all for years to come and that's it for
this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel also be sure to check out
the link to some of my longer videos in
the pin comment until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live